all right guys
bang bang i've got dan here thank you so
much for doing this thanks for having me
all right we're just gonna start right
with like the juicy stuff uh
esg bitcoins and ofac compliant blocks
what is this stuff it's having fun
staying poor
that's the tldr because if you want to
mine bitcoin using expensive electricity
that's esg compliant or esg
you know environmentally friendly you
might be paying more for it than you
would have
being a miner trying to seek out the
lowest cost energy anywhere in the world
that's what a miner should rationally do
if you decide not to do that
instead pay more for electricity to
virtue signal you're going to spend more
so give me an example
for example let's say uh you're a miner
and you could source electricity from a
source that is considered
more pollutant like a coal or something
like that unless you're paying
one two cents per kilowatt hour there
and it's four cents per kilowatt hour
coming from solar well that costs you
twice as much which will make that the
bitcoin that you mind more expensive
so people who choose the renewable
energy methods may or may not have
higher cost energy now that's not
necessarily the case because there's a
there's a lot of examples where
renewable energy is actually cheaper
than coal or other types of energy
because it's
been lin it's it's locked and you can't
distribute that electricity down a down
a line
or there's certain cycles where you have
more solar than demand
is it that then there's demand so this
isn't necessarily a
a uh a linear comparison to say like
okay uh
you know esg or environment friendly
energy uh sources are expensive
and non-energy friendly or
non-environmental friendly
sources are cheap it's not necessarily
that
but if you try to 100 get all of your
sources from it renewable
and that comes at an extra cost then you
would be incurring extra cost just to
kind of virtue signal rather than like
just being efficient and focusing on
what's the minimum cost for my
electricity
so the key for a miner is just what is
the lowest cost energy that i can
possibly
generate or yeah that's right so we can
think about bitcoin mining like you buy
a machine that prints money and it
prints money it prints bitcoin
if you throw take electricity and flow
it through that machine
and so your objective is to buy the
machines at lowest cost possible
and buy the lowest cost electricity and
then you get your highest roi on the
bitcoin the money that comes out of the
machine
and the renewable power is in many cases
cheaper or more expensive
well that's the tricky thing sometimes
it's cheaper because there's excess
capacity but if you're trying to do this
with 100
of your capacity uh for your miner
miners or sources from places that are
in the u.s and environmentally friendly
just a virtue signal
if you're trying to do that you're not
trying to optimize for lowest cost
energy it's likely that they're probably
paying a little bit more
got it and how important in the energy
consumption debate
should we be paying attention to total
energy consumption versus
what the source of the energy is well
bitcoin's not responsible for the energy
mix
bitcoin energy consumption isn't driving
nuclear
wind solar energy creation bitcoin is
simply taking the excess capacity of the
electricity grid
and using that to mine bitcoin so it's
not bitcoin's fault that the mixture is
coal plus
solar plus something else it's more
around the energy
usage total in aggregate that people are
i think more concerned about then
is the core root of the energy argument
and when you think about the total
consumption one of the things that
people don't understand
uh i literally saw a new york times
journalist uh
talk about this is wait bitcoin's energy
consumption
is you know i don't know 30 of what the
traditional banking systems
energy consumption is uh and it only
serves a fraction of the people a
fraction of the
transactions but explain how
you can actually do more transactions or
serve more people without the energy
consumption going up
yeah so let's define so when miners mine
bitcoin what they're doing is they're
mining a bitcoin block
a bitcoin block is comprised of newly
minted bitcoin plus transactions that
occurred
that's a that's one the first assumption
that most journalists make incorrectly
which is that bitcoin mining only
supports bitcoin transactions no
it's a production of new coins plus
transactions now with each transaction
each transaction can include many many
more transactions on
inside of it what i mean by that is like
for example lightning
with lightning we can open up a
lightning channel and transact millions
of times
and then settle on that base layer that
would only show up as
two transactions total so that is a lot
of energy economic density as nick
carter would put it
where millions and millions of
transactions have occurred but then
settle
net on the bitcoin layer one via one
transaction or maybe two transactions
and how many transactions fit into a
block
um that's a good question i forget it
depends on the transaction size and
bytes
and transaction size and bytes depends
on what type of signature it is
so if it's like a multi-sig versus a
signal single signature
and then there's other types of
signatures if you had a guess
ballpark it's uh what is it seven
transactions a second and you've got ten
minute blocks so it's seven times sixty
times
sixty so seven times sixty times ten
yeah thousands
but really you can be servicing every
ten minute block millions of
transactions
but whether you're doing thousands of
transactions or millions
it still takes the same energy
consumption because it's just one block
that's right yeah that's exactly right
so the energy consumption to mine a
bitcoin block will stay the same no
matter how much economic density
is inside those transactions so those
transaction transactions could represent
billions of more transactions so
essentially bitcoin's energy
is energy consumption is highly
efficient because as more and more
economic
economic activity comes down to the
bitcoin blockchain the energy
consumption
does grow but it doesn't grow in a
linear fashion with the amount of
economic activity occurring
so this is the argument that i made at
one point i wrote this thing about
the legacy system is linear you're
basically explaining why
the bitcoin system is not linear and
linear just means if i want to serve
more transactions or i want to serve
more people
i need more atms i need more banks i
need more data centers i need all the
stuff
and so in order to serve more people or
more transactions in the legacy system i
have to increase my energy consumption
here that's not necessarily true because
it's a non-linear relationship between
transactions and users
and that energy consumption exactly and
to be fair though there are layer two
technologies that would require energy
right
if you open up a lightning channel that
does require energy but for simplicity
sake yes 100
okay uh when we start to get into the
conversation
around why does the energy consumption
continue to go up
explain the relationship between uh the
bitcoin
reward and hash rate increasing right
because hash rate increasing essentially
is
uh a proxy for energy consumption going
up um
and so there is a relationship between
the more successful that bitcoin is the
more energy
consumption there is yeah but it's not
because it's serving more users or
serving more transactions it's actually
for an economic reason so explain that
yeah there's a lot of different moving
parts here so i'm going to try to make
it as simple as i can for the audience
we can think about it like goal
production so as gold becomes more and
more valuable
there's uh gold miners are willing to go
deeper and deeper into the earth to go
find it which will cost them more and
more money
bitcoin has a similar mechanism called
the difficulty adjustment
as bitcoin grows in value it becomes
more and more difficult to mine a
bitcoin because
more miners come onto the network to
mine bitcoin and then the difficulty
adjustment is an automated mechanism
that the bitcoin network has
to increase the difficulty of mining
bitcoin which makes it then competitive
with the newly added miners so newly
added miners means more people are
chasing
or more people are deploying their
hashing power to find that bitcoin block
and so bitcoin is like well i'm gonna
make it harder for y'all to go find it a
similar function would work if let's say
there's an alien species that comes down
with a alien computer that is a thousand
times more powerful than all the bitcoin
miners out there
if they start mining bitcoin's
difficulty adjustment every i think it's
two 2016 blocks would adjust for the
newly
uh brought on hash power so bitcoin's uh
difficulty adjustment
essentially adjusts for all of the
miners coming onto the network who are
trying to take advantage of bitcoin's
price rise
looking at bitcoin's price rise going
it's more and more valuable to go mine a
block
so i'm gonna turn on more hash power i'm
gonna build more miners bitcoins network
makes uh makes an equilibrium
between these newly these uh newly
brought on miners and the difficulty it
takes to bind a block of bitcoin
ofac compliant blocks is a thing that
uh i don't think anyone had talked about
previously really uh
until recently uh there's a minor um
who i always in these situations assign
um ignorance rather than malice right
uh and especially when somebody is
likely doing something because there's
an
economic advantage for them to do it
right so
uh there's a minor called marathon they
basically decided that they were going
to produce
what they titled as my understanding of
compliant blocks before we get into why
they're doing it what exactly does that
mean an ofac compliant block
yeah so ofac um i forget what the
acronym stands for but essentially it's
a
it's a global entity that looks at
different bank accounts and individuals
and puts them on a blocked list
so the list blocks them from different
financial services i think that's the
most simple form of this that i can i
can kind of compress
so ofac essentially builds out this list
of individuals they're like we've got a
scammer from russia
his name is this his bank accounts are
here these have been frozen
uh you are not permitted to do business
or bank this individual
to be basically like you're blocked from
the financial existing financial system
if you're on the ofac list so what this
miner thought they should do
was take transactions so there's
different bitcoin addresses
that have been put on ofac block lists
and so they decided to block any
transactions that would come from those
addresses
well this sort of violates the entire
principle of bitcoin the whole principle
of bitcoin is that there is no
censorship everything is
not censorable it's it's an immutable
ledger and you're able to transact as
anyone you
like no transactions can be censored and
also achieving this
is very difficult because if they don't
mine it someone else will
so essentially this miner was willing to
forego revenue
to mine uh mine these bitcoin now what's
funky about this is like
knowing which transactions are bad or
good it's almost impossible i mean
there's there's some that have been
flagged as like of non-compliant
but these are all mixed together and
then you don't know exactly who's the
owner of it
it's much more difficult to suss out
than just like oh here's a bad guy's
bank account
um so they're willing to forego revenue
it's extremely difficult to do
and then finally um fincen hasn't
required people to do this i don't i
don't think it's required now
i haven't i'm not on the legal side of
things so i haven't dug in as deep as i
as i should on this but from my
understanding fencing doesn't regulate
bitcoin miners in that fashion
if they started to to require them to
censor transactions
i think this is similarly equivalent to
requiring isps
to start to like filter like traffic
going across the internet like starting
to censor things that are going
across the internet that uh would be
like oh fact non-compliant
and i don't think they require that now
so basically this miner was going hey
we're going to virtue signal that we're
stopping the bad guys even though
we're not required to do so and it comes
at a cost to us
which i think was just a very bizarre
mixture of of things and the bitcoin
community reacted really harshly to this
naturally because this is antithetical
to what bitcoin represents
and they recently everything reversed
their decision as of was that today
it was today so uh fred teal new ceo
comes into marathon
it's unclear kind of when these
decisions were made when he stepped in
or whatever but he's stepped in and said
hey
we are not going to do this we're going
to basically act like every other miner
on the network acts we're not going to
censor anything
and this whole ofac compliant idea is
essentially getting kicked to the road
uh is there an issue
if all of a sudden a bunch of miners
came together and were like
hey we're going to do this and it's not
it wasn't just
one that could be singled out and kind
of have the pushback but it was actually
the miners right i'll put that in your
quotes as like a group of people
yeah uh certainly this would be an issue
in the future
i do think that the bitcoin network has
built-in defense mechanisms
one is incentive the other miners are
much more incentivized to go mine all
those transactions if they start
if the group of miners start to censor
um
x percentage of transactions well
they're foregoing a lot of that
that revenue and over time the bitcoin
block which is comprised of newly
emitted bitcoins plus
those transactions the bitcoin
transaction fees are starting to slowly
replace the block
subsidy which are the newly minted coins
which means that that reward that they
receive
is more and more becoming transaction
fees so if they started to heavily
sensor they would be very much
penalizing themselves
and it also means that other miners
would be willing to accept the
transaction and mine it
which then gives that faction of miners
who are non-sensor non-censoring
or the nut sensoring at all would give
them much more
revenue potential and i think that would
just is a natural incentive that would
push more and more miners over to that
faction
if you had more than 51 of the hash rate
decided to do this is that
fatal it's not fatal um this gets into
some game theory i haven't explored as
much
but essentially there are some game
theoretic attack factors here to where
this isn't a fatal thing for bitcoin
it's just a uh it's more of like it
starts to be
because there's also ways you can
obfuscate transactions like with coin
joins and other mechanisms that make
this much more difficult
same with like lightning channels that
are opened up but yeah i haven't fully
explored all of the uh
in-depth game theoretic attack factors
here yeah uh one of the things that we
have seen that's happened recently is
this whole idea of a minor council
now i'll caveat this with uh folks who
participated in this meeting
um it seems like michael saylor elon
musk and a few others all got together
there's a number of really large miners
there uh i
know many of the people who uh
participated in this or helped set it up
etc
and again just my personal opinion and
my personal experience but like
these people love bitcoin they couldn't
agree more with the ethos of bitcoin uh
and in no way do i think that they were
ever
intending to attack bitcoin be negative
adversarial any of this stuff
it was really in uh hey we want to help
bitcoin we want this to be a positive
thing
with all that said uh there's been in
the past meetings
that's just a uh uh a touchy subject uh
in bitcoin because there have been
meetings that turned into
uh kind of adversarial type uh decisions
uh
of groups of people to kind of go after
bitcoin or try to change bitcoin
and so uh part of the people who
participated in this recent meeting
um one person i forget who it was came
out and said hey listen
council's probably too strong of a word
that insinuates like
you come to us dan and we tell you as
the council like what to do
right maybe we should use the word
association or something else
but this idea of the minors coming
together
i think now has become top of minds we
were like well what are they doing what
are they talking about right and so like
what's your whole read on
minor counsel coordination transparency
that they're trying to achieve
like just what was your read to that
situation yeah there's a couple
different thoughts here one is that
bitcoin
bitcoiners naturally have an allergic
reaction to centralization
so if you have a committee or group
there's a couple different events that
occurred in in the past to that make
bitcoiners cautious of these sort of
coalitions or groups one would be the
bitcoin foundation
bitcoin foundation over time was this
thing that was an idea like let's have
this bitcoin
centralized team that can help promote
bitcoin and x do x y or z
that was corrupted uh over time same
with the new york agreement the new york
agreement was a group of businesses and
minors who came together
to try to implement segwit2x and so
that was a and then the users of the
community of bitcoin fought back against
this big business interest in trying to
change the bitcoin protocol
so naturally bitcoiners have this
allergic reaction whenever they hear the
word
coalition i don't think it was done
maliciously i agree
i do think that sailor probably could
have read up on his history a little bit
to understand that the bitcoin can or
have
hire a comms person here i think a
product like a product marketer or a
comms person would have been
required for this to have been like a
little bit smoother they could have gone
through looked at the
looked at the language looked how they
positioned this understood the community
and probably
phrased it a little bit differently
their goals i think were a little bit
strange it was
the ecg goal so more of like the
environment we are going we're a
coalition of miners
they're going to source electricity from
environmentally friendly sources
i think that because i believe at the
time that they were trying to and what
was this a week and a half ago
they were trying to counteract the
narrative that bitcoin mining is
wasteful that bitcoin mining uses
coal or or bad energy i think that
it was a good attempt to so they're
fighting fud their their narrative
fighting
and they're fighting this narrative that
bitcoin's bad for the environment i
don't think
i personally don't think their strategy
will work i hope that it does
i wish them the best but i don't think
that that narrative
will fight that other narrative very
well so the fudd narrative bitcoin is
wasteful it uses bad energy
uh they're trying to fight it by oh no
bitcoin uses good energy but i think at
the core root of this argument
it's about that bitcoin energy usage
isn't wasteful it's doing something very
useful
and bitcoin detractors use bitcoin's
dirty energy
as a way to fight it but at the core
root of their argument they just don't
think bitcoin's doing something valuable
that's why they don't like it so if
bitcoin used 100 clean energy
i still think we would see bitcoin
energy fud so ultimately i don't think
that narrative battle will be won by
this group
but i do applaud them for their efforts
to at least try yeah it also feels like
um
a lot of the esg stuff is uh
complete nonsense right not not in the
bitcoin sense but just like
overall is uh people get on private
planes waste a bunch of energy destroy
the planet to go
somewhere to yell and scream about hey
we should stop destroying the planet
and then they go back to their offices
where they're the on the executive team
of a business that's destroying the plan
like
it's all ridiculous and uh you know my
favorite
statistic out of all of this is um the
christmas light usage of electricity in
the united states is more than some
countries
yeah it is totally absurd i mean we
should cancel christmas
right and xboxes and i play xbox for fun
with me and my buddies i mean i don't
worry about xbox being wasteful
some people would find that wasteful
because they don't like to play xbox
they don't like the game
but how about watching the kardashians
or washing your clothes or
you've got an suv and i've got a toyota
prius right like it doesn't matter
like it doesn't matter about like virtue
signaling individual energy consumption
and we've if we applied the principles
in which they're evaluating bitcoin with
where they go
well what is bitcoin's energy mix how
efficient is bitcoin being
if they're really honest about it if
they actually care about the environment
which they don't
they would first look at the energy
consumption of the fiat banking system
but they never look at that and then
look at bitcoin and go oh yeah yeah okay
well bitcoin uses you know they're both
bad no they say bitcoins bad
and then they never look at everything
else like let's stack rank all the
energy consumption in the world
based on biggest energy consumers and go
look at those first to go to go tackle
the problem
that's how someone in product or growth
would go focus on it stack ranking based
on roi
they don't do that they're just like i
don't like this industry so it's
wasteful
and no one would ever ask you what the
energy mix of your washer is
i mean how much energy is your washer
like taking from coal
versus solar no one cares no one ever
asks you they'd be very impolite if they
did
but for some reason they hate bitcoin
and that's why they focus on it so much
this brings up a really interesting
point which is uh the way that
the asset is treated throughout the
media
is uh i believe unethical
right and here's a perfect example is
we have people who are told if you are a
journalist at a mainstream media
organization
and you write about an asset and you
hold that asset
you need to disclose it i have never
seen
a single article where somebody writes
and says i hold dollars
but there's a whole hell of a lot of
defending of the dollar
and attacking of a competitor in the
marketplace
it is the most absurd absurd
journalistic
integrity like level that they have is
like i will remove myself from bias by
not holding this asset
but i will hold another asset like they
hold real estate
stocks bonds fiat currency
they'll hold that and not consider that
in a conflict of interest which is just
so to be fair stocks and bonds in many
cases
are somewhat insulated so for example
there are some journalists who say hey i
won't hold individual securities
i'll buy an index fund or or whatever
right
but to your point i don't see people
right and saying i hope i hold a home
right or i hold dollars dollars is
that's the most egregious one right of
course
how do you write you're writing about
currencies and you're saying the us
dollar is great
bitcoin is bad the central bank is great
and
this decentralized system is bad but you
don't disclose
that a hundred percent of your net worth
is in the dollar-based system it's it's
a it's a faux
[ __ ] level of integrity i mean their
their integrity should be in
how factually accurate they are that is
integrity and their function
but they don't care about that what they
care about is clicks
and what they care about is this
[ __ ] integrity that they all have
amongst each other of oh i don't hold
the asset
i'm pure and i'm like well how about the
accuracy of the article you just
published which had numerous objectively
false information like
that was objectively false which you
wrote and they won't admit that
so i think it's just kind of this weird
virtue signaling thing amongst other
journalists that i'm pure
but it means nothing to everyone else in
the world when we all look at these
journalists and we hope that they would
write something that is accurate
i think that the financial media is
exponentially worse
than any other vertical of media in the
united states
because what they have done is they have
cheered on
the actions of government
administrations
and central banks that has destroyed
the bottom 50 percent of citizens wealth
yeah
like they literally cheered on if you go
and you look
who's asking the hard questions anymore
who's holding the people in power
accountable
in the financial media it's a joke well
the
the whole thing with quantitative easing
and stimulus packages are that these are
all
connected with the population so these
are free these are bailouts both
corporations and the population
and when everyone's getting handouts no
one wants to be negative right
so no one's questioning like will
anything blow up here
and the only people i ever see
commenting on that are opinion pieces
based on like old
like old economists like larry summers
he came out and he's like
this is crazy he's like what the hell
are we doing he's like the
the fed's job is to take away the punch
bowl when things get nuts instead
they're getting everyone at the party
drunk
and that's what's happening and all the
journalists are just going along with it
stanley druckenmiller one of the best
investors over the last 30 years
came out and said the federal reserve is
responsible
for is the most responsible group
for the wealth inequality over the last
decade absolutely
yeah you're talking about somebody who
like if you are i say that people are
like oh they're crazy
sure we're bitcoiners if he says it how
do you not start to say wait a second
what's he what's he saying well same
with larry summers larry summers was
treasury secretary for
clinton i believe and was uh considered
for the
chairman of the fed so larry summers
coming out and saying this is also
pretty wild too i mean he was
under a democratic he was under a
democratic president um
a democrat as a president and just to
see him come on be like talk about like
people being drunk off the punch bowl
and asleep at the wheel
this is very strong language this isn't
uh yeah we're a little bit more
rebellious
but these are people who are steeped in
sort of like the institutional side of
of of all this institutional pedigree
and all of the
interworkings of the government they're
much more they're typically much more
polite with their wording
and to see them come out like this i
think is a big sign of how far we've
come
last year we were told inflation wasn't
going to happen
now that it's happened we're being told
it's transitory right
i don't know what happens moving forward
i don't think anyone actually knows with
100 certainty
i have opinions you have opinions other
people have opinions but we don't
actually know
but what we do know with 100 certainty
is last year we were told it wasn't
going to happen
and now we're being fed a different
story with no
apology no correction no
anything to the fact that we were told
inflation was not going to happen
i you others said it was going to happen
they were wrong we were right and now
inflation is here
and now all of a sudden and not just
inflation and drastic increase in
inflation
that we were told was not going to
happen and now we're being oh don't
worry about is transitory
well they're also moving the goal posts
the fed is recalculating how they
calculate inflation
and they're they're recalculating their
targeting as well i believe the target
game before was like a
it was like a two percent inflation over
a certain duration and now they're
looking at like average
two percent inflation a year so they're
changing how they measure it
in order to give themselves more
flexibility i mean being an economist is
one of the most intellectually dishonest
sort of positions to ever be in because
when you're you're running experiments
that you can't recreate
you have no idea if it's actually
working and then when it doesn't work
you change your definition of what
actually works or like what does success
look like
it's completely ridiculous and and
what's so disturbing is how
huge this is this isn't just is it the
greatest scam
it is it's the entire monetary
manipulation of the economy
over the last 50 years is it the
greatest scam
that we will live through absolutely i
think that you know money is a
representation of energy and time
like you and i spend lots of time and
energy to go make money same with
everyone else out in the world
the government changing you know
printing more and just moving it as they
see fit to the tune of tens of trillions
you know this isn't this isn't just like
a minor thing minor corruption or
something where like a local mayor
does something kind of shady or there's
a weird business contract between
a state and a company this is the
manipulation of all money in the world
at a scale that didn't really exist
before so yeah
i would say this is one of those
greatest games of all time when you
think about
what the solution is is it bitcoin just
it literally the beautifully designed
bitcoin system or is it
some sort of complex solution that
involves other things that are social or
political
or is it just a pure economic
technological
invention like this well ultimately
bitcoin is about humans
uh believing in them at the end of the
day it requires human behavior to
reorient around a protocol
you know bitcoin is just pure raw code
if no one believed in that code it would
be worth nothing
so it requires that humans start to
believe in and start to work with it and
want to become part of that community
and also become and start to believe in
the ideals that this code or
protocol or community represents i do
think that bitcoin will be the inception
point for a more libertarian
ideology to permeate the world whereas
now we're seeing the world kind of shift
more socialist i think bitcoin kind of
forces the conversation back to being
having free markets and people willingly
choose
to engage in certain sort of business
endeavors
starting with business first then leads
you to believe
leads you to think well why is that if
the government controlled my money
now they don't then why do they control
my body and then why do they control
these other things about my life
money is the most important thing in the
world it dictates everything around us
it dictates individual freedom how free
and flexible are you to move out of bad
situations or dangerous situations or
feel safe or insecure and so once people
start to feel liberty and freedom with
their money
then they go well why are drugs legal
why why are you taxing me this much why
are x y or z i mean
the automatic withholding from w-2s
is incredible i mean it's the that is
one of the greatest
user experience things that the irs came
up with ever because then you don't even
notice
the taxes coming out of your paycheck
versus you cutting the check
and sending it to them they just
automatically withhold that
those taxes that you owe with your
employer and you don't even notice how
bad it is because you're just like oh
here's my net paycheck
what gets in my bank account and that
can pay my bills but you don't look at
the gross value where you're like whoa
i'm losing like half my money because i
live in california i mean i lose like
almost half my money to taxes and i'm
like what did i get for that
so i think that bitcoin is the inception
point where bitcoin starts to challenge
people's beliefs
over what government should control in
your life starts with money
then it permeates to everything else
when you think
in the crypto community uh there's
a whole bunch of narratives that are uh
shared
by other people outside of the bitcoin
community uh and i just want to throw
some of those out there and you kind of
run through them
uh bitcoin ethereum uh
while some people may think that they're
competitive others say they're not
competitive in terms of what they're
trying to accomplish
but there is a belief that the market
caps will flip the flipping
yes no does it matter if it happens or
if it doesn't happen
yeah good question so i think they're
trying to accomplish two different
things bitcoin is trying to go after
store value gold 2.0 thesis
be this rock solid stable trustworthy
collateral that people can believe in
and bitcoin has largely accomplished
that
it's been around for what is it was it
13 years not 12 years now
12 years um proof of work has
demonstrated its resiliency
uh institutions are buying into it its
volumes are approaching higher and
higher levels
bitcoin is is definitely being viewed as
a credible
goal 2.0 alternative like an alternative
to gold and it's being globally
recognized as that
ethereum is trying to do uh kind of like
smart contracts more of
more of like you know the common term is
d5 for this but ethereum is trying to do
something
where they take the concepts that
bitcoin had using that blockchain
technology
and then leveraging that to go build out
smart contract platforms defy
kind of have this whole ecosystem of
different uh financial services
blockchains inherently have some
limitations though so i don't think that
like you can take bitcoin's blockchain
and just copy paste that to
x y or the industry and that work out
super well
i do think some of what the ethereum
folks are working on is really
interesting
i don't think that like the ethereum
community is is incredible
ethereum is not a credible store of
value asset um
you can't change your monetary policy
every year multiple times
and then expect people to believe that
it won't change again in the future
i do think like and then also ethereum
having a low inflation rate wasn't even
a narrative until a year ago
now these are these are very new
narratives for ethereum and so
i don't think that they understand the
core principle of that trust is
built over time and there's nothing that
can replicate that
it doesn't matter what code you make
what matters is that humans over time
believed in it and as that time
increases there's more and more trust
and belief built in
yes so ethereum shifts to uh let's say
they have a this
recent monetary policy change let's say
that it has gives it a lower inflation
rate than bitcoin
that's cool but the us dollar has a low
inflation rate that doesn't make it
sound money
it's the credible monetary policy it's
belief in the monetary policy that gives
its value
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cashback or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
this is gonna be something that a lot of
people are gonna be uh not so happy with
but something i believe uh and i've been
pushing myself to say things that i
believe
uh regardless of people's reaction
bitcoin or ethereum
if you told me right now pick which one
is the quote myspace
aetherium 110 is more likely to be
disrupted by new technology by by a new
um kind of more innovative solution
than bitcoin for one simple reason
the technology of bitcoin has been
crea there's somebody's created faster
cheaper all this stuff
but you can't change the one thing that
matters which is the decentralization
right that is ultimately what is the
value is decentralization and bitcoin is
far
the most decentralized version and
because it has that massive head start
unless there was some catastrophic event
it's just you're not going to catch up
to it you're not going to be able to
beat it because decentralization comes
from time from trust also we just talked
about
totally with ethereum what
the entire premise of this was
hey we like the idea of decentralization
but we want to do more with it
right actually a pretty rational
thought process and we can't do it here
because there's not smart contracts not
composability all stuff so we're gonna
go build
our new blockchain again like pretty
rational right in terms of if you wanna
optimize for something else okay
we're gonna go build this layer one
blockchain and it's gonna be scalable
it's gonna be composable
i think most people in that community i
don't want to say everybody but most
people in that community now
uh would conclude and come to consensus
on the fact that you're not gonna scale
on a layer one on a blockchain you gotta
scale in layer two bitcoin has been
saved for a long time so i don't think
there's disagreement in that the
scalability is gonna come from these
layer twos
but what i think people are drastically
underestimating
is that already today there have been
blockchains that have been created
that are faster and cheaper than
ethereum
and they're not being ignored they're
actually in some cases
already seeing more transactions
happening on them
and so do i think that they're going to
win or not i don't know i actually don't
spend enough time to have an opinion as
like is ethereum the winner
or is one of these new players like a
binance smart chain
etc a winner i don't know
but what i do know is that the threat
that other smart contract platforms have
to ethereum
is much much higher from a probability
standpoint than anything else coming
along saying we're going to create a
decentralized
uh kind of payment system agree or
disagree with that
agreed i think that no one else no other
cryptocurrency has the credibility that
bitcoin has in terms of a store of value
i think decentralization trusts those
are all intertwined together
the decentralization leads to more trust
bitcoin's community
feeds back into the decentralization and
their it kind of completes this like
virtuous cycle
with ethereum they're trying to be a
world computer using smart contracts
defy
trying to re-envision different parts of
the economy and
with some of those decentralization
doesn't matter as much and that's where
the narrative that
decentralization isn't a binary thing
it's this gradient that narrative
started to kick in in 2017
and so with ethereum they kind of push
the envelope of like we can we can
decrease our decentralization
and increase throughput increase x y or
z functionality
but then there's always going to be a
protocol that decreases their
decentralization even more
so they lessen up on decentralization
allow more throughput and this would be
biased smartsheet would be uh finance
marching solana
the ethereum community would argue
binance smart chain
literally they scoff at it right they
thumb their nose and they say that's
stupid it has no decentralization it's
centralized
right and i think this is bitcoin you're
saying like yes because there's an
evolution of less and less
decentralization precisely if the value
prop you're competing on
is like low-cost like contracts like the
ethereum community brags about how
costly these smart contracts are to
execute i don't think a lot of financial
players want costly transactions like
they want low-cost transactions and so
with
with certain types of transactions the
affinity to go pay that higher fee is
much higher
but you know they talk about d5 being
this revolution well if it cost you 120
to swap it between two assets i don't
know if that's better or worse than the
existing financial system and we've seen
some of the large players in some of
these use cases like nfts for example
with nba top shot dapper labs
they actually moved off of ethereum and
went and built their own blockchain
specifically for their use case and so
it begs the question of
in a smart contract platform do you get
fractionalization
where people say no i'm gonna take the
idea of the smart contract platform and
i'm gonna customize it
to my specific use case versus in the
bitcoin world
there's nobody who's saying like okay
i'm gonna take bitcoin and then i'm
gonna
create a special customized version of
bitcoin
that i'm then going to go do something
on because it doesn't work
because nobody buys into the idea
because it's not a technology argument
it's a belief system argument whereas
over here on the ethereum side
it's absolutely technical uh efficiency
and technical superiority
which up until recently ethereum was the
winner from a technical
superiority standpoint for a smart
contract platform
i think now that's coming into question
as to who is going to be the long-term
winner they still have the lead
still the dominant smart contract
platform but there are all of a sudden
last 12 months became a lot of
competition very very quickly
and it's very credible competition as
well totally i mean we're talking like
there's also a network effect to this
network effective buyers believers
and developers working on those
protocols now we're seeing this start to
shift over to like binance
solana many others and i think that
that's definitely a big challenge for
ethereum is how do you preserve
decentralization
but then also uh you know trade off all
these things that these these developers
want to go build out smart contracts and
these more advanced systems
another thing that earlier this week
that came to light was really
interesting
uh maker so maker uh
explain what maker is maker dow
essentially a uh
algorithmic stable coin what that means
is that the stable coin tries to
preserve the value of
a maker dollar equivalent to a us dollar
so it's you could call it a fiat coin a
fiat coin stable coin
is a little bit of a misnomer
considering that fiat declines like at
least a couple percent a year
so they use certain types of collateral
in order to
create this peg not really a peg but or
stabilization mechanism
so this collateral is being more and
more this more and more of this
collateral and i think now it's like 30
or 40 percent
is usdc which means that makerdale
collateral is simply
uh a centralized stablecoin so a
decentralized system
is relying on a centralized asset that's
ordered to keep the peg
yeah because usdc usct are completely
centralized transactions can be censored
coins can be moved uh how these work at
usdc usdc they have a real us dollar
bank account
and then they issue you a token to
represent that dollar
and so what maker dial is now having as
their collateral
are these usdc reserves which
essentially means that it's
they're using completely centralized
collateral which in a second could be
gone
so you can't be a decentralized system
if you use centralized assets or do you
think there's a world where a
decentralized system could use
centralized assets i don't think so i
think that you need to have
decentralized assets because that's the
whole core root of it is having like
the ownership of the assets needs to
remain in the digital world rather than
being tied to something the physical one
we're trying tied to the existing
financial system that's why i really
believe you know i'm really
a strong believer in like native assets
whenever you introduce like a legacy
financial asset into a blockchain
ecosystem
you introduce a lot of risk so let's say
you introduced a stablecoin
and now your smart contract uses that
stable coin in some sort of fashion
well we have to trust that stablecoin
won't be seized or
reversed and then same with other
collateral like you take a real piece of
real estate
tokenize that put it on the blockchain
if that's on the blockchain
and it's being used for smart contracts
it's still rooted in the existing
financial system which can be censored
at a moment's notice so a blockchain
doesn't really add that much more value
so
yeah i don't believe it's called
decentralization when you have an asset
that's completely controllable and
centralized
in a d and a d phi or uh you know a d
fire blockchain ecosystem because at
that point it's basically just you know
traditional finance on the blockchain
which doesn't give you much more value
than what the you know blockchain was
supposed to bring you which is
decentralization
permits permissionless innovation on
censorable
transactions if you were uh in charge of
or a major voice in one of these smart
contract
platforms or communities what would your
advice to them be would it be to say hey
listen we're not optimizing for
decentralization decentralization
actually really doesn't matter that much
and so we're just purely going to be the
most effective
uh technical platform for people to come
and build on
would it be no don't ever say that you
should try to make it as decentralized
as possible like like
almost like flip to the other side of
the table and like what would your
advice be in terms of
achieving success if you're a part of
the smart contract platforms
yeah if i was a marketer for these smart
contract platforms you're not really
competing on decentralization it's clear
that
those community members don't care as
much as bitcoiners care about
decentralization
i think they do care to a degree but as
we're seeing with binance smart
smart chain like people don't care as
much traders don't care as much so you
really have to compete more on the
aspects of flexibility
composability all these different things
that make smart contract technology very
useful for engineers who want to build
cool fun things and so that's your
marketing pitch
is the flexibility of it what can it do
for you
as a developer what can you build with
it as a consumer what problem will it
solve for you
and decentralization isn't necessarily
you know you're not capable of
maintaining decentralization on that
gradient of bitcoin be the max
decentralization
you can have and hold that
decentralization all the way through
to the smart contract functionality uh
to some degree you can but
it you lose some of that over time and
so if they're trying to market and
they're trying to compete against
ethereum
i would say their narrative should
probably be more around flexibility and
and that's the narrative that these
developers and these consumers care
about
these consumers doesn't seem care about
as much about decentralization as
the hardcore bitcoin community would
bitcoin defy or defy on bitcoin
have you spent any time on this what are
your thoughts what's exciting not
exciting
yeah so i'm just about to uh explore
this myself okay
what i like to do is when i learn about
a new topic i start to write about it
that helps me kind of switch the uh the
role around to a teacher mode
where i'm able to think about it from i
have to teach it and the best way to
understand something just to try to
teach it
so i'm undergoing the process right now
of learning more about stacks
sovereign sovereign is like sovereign
rsk
um atomic finance which is using dlcs
and um i think a few more but that this
is those are the three top ones
i'm an investor in two of those perfect
[Laughter]
well atomic and sovereign yeah well i
think they're both super interesting in
the atomic
and a very big fan of munib and the
stacks team and i've known a lot of
these people for a long long time
on all three teams you wanna hear a
crazy stat sure
i believe this to be true uh it was told
to me by somebody who
i trust believe i actually don't even
know how i would go figure this out uh
um but stacks went from zero dollars in
total value locked to a billion dollars
the second fastest in history wow now
price has come down a lot and so i don't
think that they're still at a billion
dollars of total value locked
i think that's true of a lot of these
platforms as prices come down kind of
the
total value lock contracts but they went
from zero to a billion i think only
sushi swap
was faster and maybe it's not the second
fastest maybe they're the fifth fastest
or something right whatever
still very fast but still uh
very very quickly another great stat for
you
d5 pulse does not list them
you know the top rankings of total value
locked
why don't they list them well i don't
know
is a short answer okay i can
guess my guess is that there would be a
lot of blowback
if something that is very focused on the
ethereum smart contract platform
defy would then all of a sudden put in
the top
five or ten or whatever products yeah
defy on bitcoin product it would be a
little bit controversial but
i think from what we've seen that i
could see them
intentionally leaving that out so it's a
convenient narrative
i think that you know bitcoin d5 so i'm
just starting my exploration now
which is i find really fun just kind of
exploring something new
and bitcoin by itself
is all that we need bitcoin is a supreme
gold 2.0 asset and everything that
bitcoin has today
enables it to be that bitcoin has found
protocol market fit
whereas i think um you know ethereum is
just finding some of that now another
smart contract
much more contract chains are trying to
find that bitcoin has found product
market fit and has found it for a very
long time
so that is the need to have bitcoin's
parameters as a sound money
it needs to have built into its
community and its protocol
on layer one and it has all of that
bitcoin d5
i think is a nice to have it's a nice to
have that unlocks some additional
functionality to bitcoin
but bitcoin would still be successful
without it but i do think it's really
really exciting to see what bitcoin can
do when you have that rock solid
trustworthy decentralized
foundation and then building on top of
that versus other systems which aren't
as decentralized
and then build skyscrapers on
skyscrapers which could lead to riskier
and risky situations where the core
base of it isn't stable whereas
bitcoin's core base is extremely stable
and bitcoin's engineers and community
have pushed innovation to layer two
which is some of this bitcoin defy these
bitcoin d5 projects are essentially like
layer two technologies
and for those that don't know what we're
talking about here from uh kind of defy
on bitcoin
is essentially uh as we described
earlier bitcoin was created
people wanted to do things like smart
contracts composability et cetera on top
of it
they then went and built ethereum now
many other smart contract platforms
those don't scale layer one for the most
part so they're building on layer two
but you get decentralized lending
decentralized exchanges
knock yourself out name your financial
product there's a decentralized version
of it
um decentralized derivatives all this
stuff uh
varying degrees of success something
like a unit swap i think now is doing
like a third of all trading volume of a
coin base
right so like if you just look at pure
stats you have to say
that one is super impressive two it
couldn't works
right three people want to use it and
they are using it right right
what the logic of define on bitcoin is
okay but let's go build decentralized
exchanges lending etc on top of bitcoin
historically that wasn't truly possible
now could you do some stuff around smart
contracts for a long time yes
but this is now with rsk and a lot of
this stuff the first time that really
any developer in the world can come and
use smart contracts stacks has done this
as well with
clarity and all stuff and so
now you start to say wait a second
there's two different ways to do d5 on
bitcoin
one is vertically integrated bitcoin
only we're gonna create non-custodial
lending exchanges all that stuff
two is something more akin to like a
sovereign
where they're saying wait a second no
what happens if you can take your
ethereum and move it over here
yeah right what happens when there's
interoperability between this stuff
but it's all rooted and secured by the
bitcoin blockchain
and they recently opened that bridge and
actually a lot of people decided to move
their ethereum over
right totally and so in that world
that's not a bitcoin versus ethereum
like those things are working together
now
right right and you get composability
you get a lot of smart contract
capabilities but you also get security
and it becomes interesting yeah i think
the entire crypto community would agree
that
bitcoin's network is one of the most
secure and decentralized it is the most
secure decentralized out there
and building on top of that gives you
the strongest foundation to build upon i
think that's what bitcoin d5 is so
interesting
what's so interesting about it is the
the bitcoin's decentralization was
preserved
preserved on layer one and then the
innovation was popped to layer two
and that's why i think it's really cool
to see the bitcoin community embrace
some of these new ideas
we can also look at it from the
perspective of you've got
uh you know you've got bitcoin which the
value accrues to bitcoin based on how
many people store value in it bitcoin is
a gold or a money after all
so the value that accretes the accrues
to the bitcoin protocol
is based on the aggregate shared belief
in bitcoin and the amount of money
flowing into it
ethereum's hypothesis was that the
utility
or the flexibility of how many things
you could do with that collateral
would increase incremental value for it
i mean ethereum's original pitch was
being an oil
not being a store of value is it
ethereum is the oil ethereum is the
the gas i mean that's why they call it
gas to power smart contracts
um and so the value would accrue based
on the utilization
of it using being able to all the
flexibility kind of like saying that
aluminum should be more valuable than
gold because you could do more things
with it
but with bitcoin d5 i think what's so
interesting is that bitcoin the value
accrues to the protocol based on the
trustworthiness based on people storing
value in it that already happened
then you have bitcoin d5 which then lets
people do more things on it that's why i
called it nice to have
is it's not critical for bitcoin to
achieve its mission of store value
it just unlocks additional functionality
um so i think that's
i don't know if that was too confusing
but those are two different i would say
it's a different
philosophy of how value accrues to the
protocol and that's important to call
out so
i think it's also important just to
state bitcoin's going after this global
store of value
ethereum and other smart contract
platforms uh are going after more of a
technical
superiority to it i
and i i don't know where you stand this
but me personally it's not that i'm
anti-any one of those smart contract
platforms i actually think that there's
way more risk of disruption and lack of
sustainability
when you get into a technical
superiority in the early days right
there's 27 search engines before google
came along
right exactly there's been a lot of
social networks so facebook came along
right and so
when you get that what ends up happening
is once a technical superiority
conversation
disruption is actually the default right
his history would tell us
it's more likely than not store of value
though
that's not true and so in some weird way
the
bitcoin community is the most
conservative
right like it is now called boomer coin
and i always tell like institutions i'm
like by the way you think this is risky
the people in this industry think this
is the least risky most conservative
most antiquated thing in the world so
when you take
the most you know i'll use the term
cowboy but in an endearing way right or
the d
gen community or whatever the the latest
nomenclatures
and you put them in a room with the
institutional the institutional people
think the bitcoiners are crazy
and and the crypto community thinks that
bitcoiners are like
so out of touch with reality and like
what's possible
that to me is actually really
interesting because now what you get is
like
that's the bridge between the two worlds
right that's how you pull
the legacy people in and you know most
people in the crypto community maybe not
everybody but most people
are bitcoiners and some people are
bitcoiners plus whatever else
right is that kind of your read as well
metallic owns bitcoin
yeah yeah so yeah and and i don't think
that
uh most people are anti-assets
i actually think what happens in the
entire industry is people are
anti-communities
well i think that it's deeper than that
too like i've been around i've been in
that bitcoin ecosystem for eight years
[ __ ] eternity i mean i've got gray
beers coming in my beard and i'm 33.
it's ridiculous
i've been through a lot right i've seen
my net worth go up exponentially and
drop 85
three times it's nuts
there's been 10 000 cryptocurrencies
that i've seen come and go
bitcoiners are rightfully skeptical of
certain claims
certain claims so we will have more
transactions per second
well cool what are you trading off for
that i think that should also this
should always be your first inclination
when a coin says we're better at this
than bitcoin the question should be
cool what are you sacrificing to get
that there's always trade-offs the world
typically doesn't have this
perfect scenario where you don't trade
off anything for something else
and bitcoiners i think are just
developed like an allergy to
these claims of like we're faster we're
more transactions per second than
bitcoin we're
uh more secure than bitcoin all of these
are dubious claims
and bitcoiners and myself included over
time and i've played around with alts
before
i traded litecoin i thought it was
faster than bitcoin yeah this is back in
2013 right
when i was first developed developing my
my understanding of the space
and then with bitcoin mining i was like
oh that seems kind of wasteful this was
in 2014 and i mined prime coin
primecoin found prime numbers while at
mind which i felt was
a better thing to do it's silly in
retrospect but
most bitcoiners didn't start 100 bitcoin
they tried everything else
and then they came back to bitcoin
because they're like this is the reason
why we're here
and so i think that um you know with
bitcoin and institutions
they're wanting to buy bitcoin bitcoin
makes sense them it's a gold 2.0
narrative
i think with the d5 products they're
certainly interesting it's really cool
to see what what happens there
but bitcoin is the gateway for that the
gateway isn't like
oh i heard about bitcoin and now i'm
gonna go buy this like really crazy new
new something swap you know sort of like
new concept
it's more of like they'll develop trust
in bitcoin and trust develops over time
and then they'll start to develop trust
in some of these other defy tools and if
that defi is built on bitcoin
then they'll naturally kind of flow into
that taproot
what is it and what is the benefit to
bitcoin so taproot is a bip
uh and what a bip is is a it's a
proposal of a new implementation of the
bitcoin code
so um different new bitcoin improvements
are proposed by the community proposed
by developers it goes through a long
process of review
and then it's there's a certain complex
process of how the market signals
including miners and users of if they
want to implement this
this new code because ultimately what
bitcoin represents is all the code that
we all run
and that we call bitcoin that's bitcoins
community bitcoins code
anyone can take bitcoin fork it create
their own version and try to get a
community of people to believe in that
so ultimately bitcoin's code and
community believe in that code is what
bitcoin represents
taproot is a new improvement that will
improve the efficiency
of transactions so i believe that you
can i forget exactly the functionality
of what it does
in terms of like how efficient it is but
i know it's more efficient
contract-wise so it makes the
transactions
in bytes smaller for certain types of
contracts and it obfuscates
certain types of a little bit more
privacy as well precisely
that's the simple way to put it so some
i believe that like
you won't be able to tell the difference
between a single signs transaction and a
multi-signal transfer transaction
so it makes more complex transaction
types somewhat look the same
so it increases privacy on on layer one
so it creases uh
more efficient block size wise so it
makes transactions smaller
and it improves privacy is kind of the
tldr
and as this improvement
becomes signal across the network and
people are going to adopt it
what happens to the people who don't
adopt it do they just
end up on a fork do they end up on old
software like what happens to them
yeah so most bitcoin bips are softworks
which means that it if you don't run the
newest version you can still interact
with the bitcoin protocol
so in this case i believe that this is a
soft work so it wouldn't it
wouldn't so if you don't upgrade to the
newest version of bitcoin
which would be compatible with taproot
you would still be able to communicate
with the bitcoin network and still be
able to integrate with it
and that's i think a much more i think
that sort of upgrade process in the
bitcoin community is somewhat unique
i know in the ethereum community they
often embrace hard forks which i think
is a much more
i think uh you're requiring consensus to
to be recreated
around this new code and that could
eventually lead to a fracture there
could be a moment when there's a hard
fork and the two groups split
versus bitcoin wants to preserve the
network effect and community
so they make that they make sure that
it's all softworks which means that
everyone
using the legacy systems can still
communicate going forward and that's
not uh an ethereum only thing right
there sure obviously there was the
ethereum ethereum classic kind of hard
fork uh but also there's bitcoin bitcoin
cash and you kind of go through all the
various forms and so really just a hard
fork becomes a little bit more
contentious a little bit more
uh divisive right i mean literally it's
like a hard fork uh whereas the soft
fork allows for
uh the uh compatibility
when you see things like this does it
give you hope that we're just gonna
continue to improve it it's gonna become
more efficient
more private and like all of the fun not
just put
very overgeneralization of just whatever
people want to say against bitcoin
is ultimately just gonna be on the wrong
side of history
yeah i think all the fud will be on the
wrong side of history most the fight is
unsubstantiated and or intellectually
dishonest
like the ecg fud again no one looks at
their own energy mix of their
radio or car or anything else they just
go use it
um so a lot of the foot is rooted in
just like people don't like bitcoin
some of the fud around like oh bitcoin
can't upgrade fast enough
i don't think is good fud either because
bitcoin being a store of value asset we
don't want it changing all the time
you worked at snapchat and facebook
right i worked at uber
we have to go ship week over week and
build new features to out-compete each
other
especially with snapchat and facebook
those are those are very intense with
the instagram and
the snapchat side uber was competing
with all these other ride-sharing
companies like lyft
but lyft was just one of them there were
dozens across the world
so the software building culture of
silicon valley is always about shipping
we've got to go ship ship ship and now
compete if we're not shipping we're
falling behind
and so it's always about releasing more
and more code to solve problems for our
customers in an elegant fashion
with a protocol like bitcoin you don't
want it to change constantly
the whole trust of the world is being
built on top of this solid foundation
all of this trust needs to believe that
this won't change very often
you don't want the foundation of a
building being swapped out for a
different type of concrete every couple
years
you want it to slowly dry and become
harder and harder over time and that's
what bitcoin is becoming
the term is called ossification so there
are there will be small changes to
bitcoin over time but i don't believe
that we'll see
that many changes over time to the
bitcoin protocol and hopefully by the
end of our lifetimes
we won't see any changes ever to become
this rock solid
never changing base with the financial
world and all the innovation happens on
layer 2 and 3.
what are you most excited about right
now in bitcoin like in terms of some of
that layer two layer three stuff
uh anything on layer one is it anything
that's non-technical from like a social
or political standpoint
when you think of bitcoin today what are
you most excited about
yeah that's a hard question answer
there's a lot of things going on i think
that
i've been in for a long long time i
think was it ari paul he said
there's more speakers at bitcoin 2021
than there were a conference attendees
back in 2014.
he's right i was at that conference at
the roosevelt
in 2014 there are more speakers than
attendees back then
so seeing the bitcoin community this big
this big is incredible
we have come so far the bitcoin has
overcome so many different obstacles to
be here today and being recognized as a
goal 2.0
by institutions and when the
institutions believe in it that brings
more retail
and this is like bitcoin's big moment
you know i think what was it 20 million
americans owned bitcoin or that was the
latest
maybe he's even hired maybe he's like
higher there's like 100 million or
something
20 yeah 20 of us adults own bitcoin
that's incredible i mean when i was in
it almost no one talked about it so
i'm most proud of that i think that's
what makes me excited is seeing the
bitcoin community grow so large
um you know on a more technical side you
know
seeing tapper get activated i think is
really cool and i think there was some
anxiety around how it would become
activated and luckily it was not
contentious
so i think that's kind of a sigh of
relief um and then bitcoin d5 i think
bitcoin d5 is super interesting
bitcoin defy i think is is something
that unlocks more functionality for
bitcoin
again i think it's a nice to have it's
not necessarily need to have for bitcoin
to win
but i'm really excited to see what
happens when developers build on the
rock solid foundation of bitcoin
versus i think a little bit more
unstable or ever-changing foundation of
some of these other protocols
last question for you elon musk does he
matter does he not
what do you think about the tweets
should he stop tweeting should he keep
tweeting
just what's your general sense of the
entire situation bitcoin has no leaders
we don't matter in bitcoin the grand
scheme of things for bitcoin none of the
core devs matter
bitcoin is a protocol and has a
community that rallies around it and
rallies behind the rules
rules not rulers and so bitcoin doesn't
need elon musk elon musk
doesn't impact bitcoin over the long
term elon musk is one of many wealthy
and powerful people that have tried to
change bitcoin do i think elon was being
serious though
i don't think so i mean he's a really
smart guy he he was talking about very
i don't know the way that he phrased it
i just it's hard for me to believe that
he was being completely truthful there
he either has
a political agenda that he needs to
signal to the existing establishment
and that's what he was doing there or he
was joking but i i
it would be hard for me to believe he
didn't spend more than 10 minutes doing
due diligence on bitcoin when they
bought it
so bitcoin doesn't need elon but i would
still like elon to
to you know become closer with the
bitcoin community and either stop joking
around or stop virtue signaling whatever
he's trying to do
because i think it'd be great to have
him on our side i don't think bitcoin
needs him but i think it'd be good to
have him
i think that's exactly how i feel is
without elon musk bitcoin will be fine
if elon musk chooses to attack bitcoin i
actually think bitcoin gets stronger and
elon would lose that battle
but i sure as hell would love to have
them on our team i agreed
better be on our team than on another
team yeah so
yeah i very much hope that he digs in
further starts to understand bitcoin a
little bit more
i'm sure there's all sorts of bitcoiners
across the world trying to help clarify
that with him so
i'm i'm pretty confident once he digs in
he'll understand it i mean bitcoin's
proof of work mechanism is about physics
not code
and i think he'd really appreciate that
if he dug in he'd find it beautiful
again he builds rockets right like he's
all about physics
um so yeah i i really hope he comes back
around and just
digs in a little bit more and decides to
it's so hard to read elon i just
it's really difficult but anyways i
think it'd be better to have them than
not to have them
i completely agree where can i send
people to find you on the internet
uh read some of your writing or any of
your other work yeah so if you're on
twitter it's
dan held if you like watching youtube
dan held as my youtube channel
uh on both i cover a variety of topics
on bitcoin i also have long form content
that i put out every thursday it's
called the held report and in the held
report i write
long form thoughts around elon inflation
and all sorts of other things awesome uh
at dan held i
multiple people asked me if you were
never changed your name to huddle uh
which i'm sure you hear all the time
uh but we will uh we'll bring you back
if you ever decided to officially change
your name to dan hoddle
sounds good well you know hopefully
bitcoin's closer to a million when that
happens but yeah bitcoin's closer to a
million i might get a bitcoin tattoo and
change my name
all right man thank you so much for
doing this i think people really learn a
lot
thanks for having me bob cheers